how will you plot the complex number A
plus bi on the Argand play assume a and
B are both positive we will move a units
right on the real axis and B units up to
get to the point a comma B we can call
it point B and let's say the erogenous
point O now just focus on point B if you
want to ask your friend to plot point B
how would you do it your friend just has
an empty graph in front of her and you
want to ask her to plot point B let's
move this graph to the left and have an
empty one on the right so one thing you
could tell your friend is move a units
to the right and B units upwards and you
will get point P is there any other way
in which you can ask her to plot this
point let me give you a hint
I joined points o and P I'll call this
angle theta and assume this length is r
this was a big big hint what can you
tell your friend such that she plots
point B correctly well you can tell your
friend two things first the distance of
points B from the origin and second the
angle at which length OB is placed from
the positive side of the horizontal axis
so if you tell her that point B is our
units long at an angle of theta degrees
from the positive x-axis she will be
able to precisely plot point B so this
was another way to represent point B you
can either give her a and B or R an
theta
in either case she will be able to plot
point P this thing you see on the right
is the polar representation of a complex
number nothing different and nothing
fancy it's the same concept they're just
using different parameters to represent
point P we will continue with this
concept in the next part of the video
[Music]